[Musik]
die ecotel de lausanne gehört zu den
renommiertesten handels schulen für die
hotelindustrie 2800 studenten aus über
110 nationen streben an der ehl nach
exzellenz können uns selbstbewusstsein
wir begleiten drei studenten im
vorbereitungsjahr und zwei am ende ihres
studiums
[Musik]
alexander schal er 18 jahre alt mit
seiner matura in der tasche geht er in
das vorbereitungsjahr immer bitte ist 21
sie wurde in der genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ein studium an dieser
internationalen schule genau wie alex
119 jahre alt der sohn eines hoteliers
geht mit selbstvertrauen ins erste
semester annina von falkenstein mit 21
beginnt sie ihre vorletzte studienjahr
die junge bärin strebt nach nichts
weniger als exzellenz auf rebecca 27
startet sein letztes semester der
energetische afri möchte selbständiger
unternehmer werden
[Musik]
letztes mal in der hotelfachschule der
junge alex beginnt seinen letzten
workshop den service im
gourmetrestaurant der schule
generalprobe mit seinem chef
madame es gibt zwei menüs zur auswahl
die man nicht kombinieren kann
annina und ihr team bereiten sich auf
das abschlussdiplom vor
sie arbeiten an einem business projekt
für eine grossbank wer wird es
präsentieren
vielleicht bin ich es immer rennt von
einem termin zum nächsten um ein
praktikum zu ergattern
obligatorisch im vorbereitungsjahr ich
habe schon zwei vorstellungsgespräche
hinter mir ich bin also nicht mehr so
aufgeregt alexandra hat sich sehr spät
um das praktikum gekümmert dank seines
vaters hat er einen termin in einem
genfer luxushotel bekommen
ich hoffe dass er das gut läuft ich weiß
nicht wieso es nicht klappen sollte
afrim ist weit weg von den sorgen des
vorbereitungs jahres für 200 seiner mit
absolventen hat er die abschlussreise
nach thailand organisiert eine woche
treten dann zurück ins reale leben auf
ihn wartet nun die arbeitswelt
sehr cool ich mag es mit leuten zu
diskutieren in einer verkaufs atmosphäre
[Musik]
ein sonniger morgen von dem alex nicht
profitiert mitten im praktikum rackert
er sich ab und ist ein wenig deprimiert
so schönes wetter
alex kimmels du dich um den staubsauger
kannst du auch die servietten falten
ja ok staubsauger servierten alles gut
der schwierigste an diesem job arbeiten
während die anderen drei jahren strebt
du immer noch eine hotel karriere an
ganz ehrlich nein die arbeitszeiten und
so ja ich habe es gesehen und das reicht
mir dieser lebensrhythmus packt mich
jetzt schon an
nach den osterferien habe ich gemerkt
dass es echt scheiße ist meine freunde
sind draußen während ich arbeite das tut
weh
[Musik]
auch immer macht ihn genf ein praktikum
und die welt die sie entdeckt gibt auch
hier einen guten grund zu murren
ich arbeite pro woche sieben stunden
mehr als in einem normalen praktikum in
der schweiz und jetzt wollen die sogar
ein ärztliches zeugnis für zwei stunden
absenz wir sind nicht sehr korrekt ich
habe kein male keine kasse wie kann man
ohne kasse an einer rezeption arbeiten
die kunden wollen wechselgeld sie wollen
bezahlen und was machst du dann
ich sage im moment bitte ich muss meine
kollegen fragen die leute halten mich
für eine touristin
was machst du hier
ich kaufe ein pflaster um ein tattoo zu
kaschieren das musst du abdecken
sind die gut die nehme ich immer und
wenn du zu spät kommst
das sehen die nicht gern vor allem weil
ich sehr oft verspätet bin wegen des
busverkehrs
ich denke das tolerieren sie jetzt nicht
mehr ich muss vermeiden ein schlechtes
bild abzugeben
[Musik]
siehst du einen großen unterschied zur
schule
ja es ist schon nicht das gleiche hier
ist man eben wirklich im aktiven leben
das hat mich anfangs ziemlich geschockt
das erste praktikum in der hotellerie
ist ein bisschen hart
man wird mit den problemen eines ersten
praktikums konfrontiert das kennen wir
alle
wir haben alle mal so angefangen der
erste schritt ist den praktikanten zu
zeigen was es heißt wirklich zu arbeiten
bei alex hat dieser prozess
glücklicherweise nicht sehr lange
gedauert
er ist ein junger mann deschanel
versteht was man von ihm verlangt
derzeit guten einsatz
was in diesem berufsfeld sehr wichtig
ist alex am apparat ich höre
okay kein problem ja gesagt vergessen
sie nicht um 6.15 muss alles bereit sein
und dann das briefing ja ich weiß
[Musik]
annina und ihr team präsentieren ihre
abschlussarbeit der jury der ehl und der
grossbank die ihnen den auftrag gegeben
hat ich werde einfach kontakte und am
schluss noch konklusion gab sich nehmen
ihre präsentation findet unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit statt
oder fast
zurück in lausanne geht afr ihm in
seiner überraschend günstige wohnung 900
franken im monat fast im zentrum
zweieinhalb zimmer 65 quadratmeter ganz
ehrlich solche wohnungen gibt es nicht
mehr
ich werde diese wohnung noch eine weile
behalten wie viel geld brauchst du im
monat kommt darauf an wie oft ich
ausgehe
eigentlich nicht wirklich viel ich muss
mein handy die wohnung die
versicherungen und ein paar ausflüge
bezahlen
das ist ja nicht viel wie finanziert du
dein leben
ich habe ein paar nebenjobs und plane
ein restaurant zu eröffnen
ich suche nach den idealen ort
das ganze ist sehr teuer wenn nicht
tausende von franken in einen ort
investieren der ihn später nicht gefällt
nicht ideal lässt ich habe mir
verschiedene sports an und so etwas
passieren ich möchte mein eigenes
business eröffnen das wäre toll
[Musik]
annina und ihre kollegen sind
erleichtert ihre präsentation beendet zu
haben und sie sind nicht allzu besorgt
während die jury sich bereit
wir waren beeindruckt von drei dingen
erstens von ihnen allen persönlich
zweitens von ihren resultaten und
drittens von der qualität ihrer
präsentation aber auch von der
dekoration die sie installiert haben
das ist die beste spp gruppe die ich je
bekleidet habe und auf die die mir am
meisten spaß gemacht hat
ein erfolg von annina und ihrem team
erhofft und vorhergesehen
die jury gratuliert zur hervorragenden
projektarbeit wird sich das sicher
erkennt an dass wir als gruppe
kritischer für das bedeutet mir so viel
will das ist mir zu viele studenten dass
wir sind viele projekte stattfinden
ziemlich cool
immer zeigt uns ihr zimmer das sie in
genf gemietet hat die küche die katze
gips sie ins zimmer
es waren arbeitest du mitternacht ich
will nicht gehen
wir waren die ersten tage ich kam in
einer hektischen phase da war der
autosalon es gar personalwechsel
[Musik]
ich habe einige fehler gemacht
ein kunde hätte 3000 franken zahlen
müssen und ich habe es vergessen er ist
gegangen aber ich glaube das hat sich
geklärt
ich habe einen kunden ein ungereinigt
ins zimmer zugewiesen mir wurde gesagt
dass ich besser aufpassen muss es ist
einfach schwierig in dieser phase wenn
man neu in ein team kommt und gar nichts
weiß und die kunden haben vielleicht
nicht verstanden warum ich gewisse
fragen nicht beantworten konnte es war
stressig wie viel bezahlen sie den
praktikanten den mindestlohn für ein
praktikum 1979
[Musik]
für alex schlägt die stunde des
briefings ein unausweichliches ritual
wenn man in einem luxushotel arbeitet
heute abend marion im saal und alex
hinten im chalet alex die stecken für
elf personen 6 vorne und 5 gegenüber der
privat salon ist im chalet stil gehalten
elf leute 246 18
ich soll diesen tisch machen ich habe
glück es schon fast komplett gedeckt mal
schauen ob sein vorgesetzter auf der
meinung ist
nein stellt das so hin gegenüber vom
gast wenn er kommt wo ist das besteck
für den fisch
ich habe dir doch gesagt 6 auf dieser
seite und 5 auf der anderen und den
teller nicht auf dem set verzeihung chef
kein problem
vorhin habe ich ihn gefragt fisch
gesteckt er hat gesagt nein dann hätte
ich gesagt okay
und jetzt fragt er wo ist das besteck
dankeschön alexandra ist dafür
verantwortlich die menü teller aus der
küche dahin zu bringen wo die kellner
übernehmen
man muss aufmerksam sein
der chef ruft ständig elabo imago dann
muss alles schnell gehen
eine warme mahlzeit darf nicht kalt
werden man muss die tickets gut
organisieren um genau zu wissen was man
wo und wann servieren muss hilfe 35 ich
muss noch aufräumen sollte um
mitternacht fertig sein und morgen um 10
uhr wieder anfangen es werden sechs
schwierige monate
[Musik]
dieselbe leier für alex unter den augen
seines chefs ich habe alles brot
weggeräumt ich habe alle kühlschränke
geschlossen die spülmaschine
ausgeschaltet ich kontrolliere das der
muss immer alles kontrollieren bevor ich
gehen kann noch nicht fertig gerade
fertig geworden das war krank alter so
was habe ich noch nie gesehen
der chef hat einen praktikanten voll
angebrüllt verpiss dich du bist gefeuert
morgen sehe ich deine scheiss papiere
auf meinem schreibtisch und dann bist du
raus was der platz der praktikanten ist
ganz unten auf der leiter und einige
chefs lassen ihren frust an ihnen aus
manchmal als ich gehen wollte sagte er
staubt es gibt noch dies und das zu
erledigen und ich als praktikant dachte
okay ich halte meine klappe machen
erwartet er immer bis kurz vor schluss
so mir das zu sagen
und du kannst nichts machen
honda radina und ihr top team kommen um
ihre arbeit einer direktions delegation
der grossbank vorzustellen die sie
beauftragt hat nervös ein bisschen
aufgeregt
unsere recherchen haben ergeben dass
junge leute die bank als nicht
transparent wahrnehmen
hier sind unsere ideen um diesen ruf zu
korrigieren ihre leuchtturm idee die
universitäten besuchen um studenten eine
gute finanzielle beratung zu bieten
ich glaube an der uni st gallen zum
beispiel hat eine andere bank das
monopol
ja die ist dort schon aktiv könnten wir
uns da überhaupt noch positionieren
könnte schwierig seien nicht
ein kleines problem
das team kann die aufgeworfene frage
nicht beantworten
mein nächstes meeting ist in zwei
minuten
ich bin schon fast verspätet aber ich
möchte ihnen gratulieren sie haben eine
wirklich beeindruckende arbeit
abgeliefert
vielen dank danke dass sie uns empfangen
haben
wir arbeiten regelmäßig mit schülern der
ehl die sind für mich sehr interessant
weil sie einen vorteil mitbringen
das sind leute mit selbstbewusstsein und
einer perfekten haltung die ich suche
und mit der richtigen einstellung lernt
man alles dass sie sich noch nicht in
der finanzwelt auskennen ist für mich
kein problem
was zählt ist die gute einstellung so
kann man alles erreichen was man will
die generation wichtig das ist aber doch
mit allen hatte man zu einer absolut
unterstützen hält es nicht
[Musik]
immer trifft ihre zwillingsschwester
julia thimm haus ihres vaters immer hat
gerade eine zeit voller wendungen hinter
sich sie ist nicht sicher ob die
unerbittliche welt der großen hotels ihr
ding ist
ich habe entschieden das praktikum
frühzeitig abzubrechen aus verschiedenen
gründen
ich musste dann während ich noch im
interkontinental arbeitete den ganzen
papierkram erledigen
für die bestätigung eines neuen
praktikums ich musste schnell reagieren
immer hat ein neues praktikum in
lausanne gefunden
eine gelegenheit näher bei ihrer familie
zu sein ja ich war in den letzten jahren
nicht auf zu hause bei meinen eltern
meiner schwester wie ist das
zusammenleben
na ja es geht man gewöhnt sich dran
das praktikum von alex in genf hat ihm
erlaubt seinen zwillingsbruder
regelmäßig zu treffen aber loris schaut
sehr ironisch auf den weg den sein
bruder der welt hat er würde sagen ich
werde bezahlt um kvaca mole zu machen
dhl ist eine sehr gute schule
aber ich denke er ist sich nicht des
glücks bewusst dass er hat er kann nur
auf diese renommierte schule weil wir
die finanziellen mittel dazu haben halt
die klappe stimmt gar nicht
ich habe die sechs monate einigermassen
ausgehalten ohne ihn aber es ist jetzt
schön ihn wieder zu sehen
es ist normal dass in diesem alter jeder
seinen weg geht als zwillinge machen wir
viele faxen die nur wir verstehen weil
wir viel zusammen sind
der nachteil von zwillingsbrüdern man
sollte immer gleich sein
es ist schwierig kritik von einander zu
akzeptieren aber es gibt eine
unglaubliche verbundenheit
trotz
[Musik]
die wochen vergehen und alexandra schaut
zurück auf sein praktikum ein geschmack
von der schärfe wie damals als sie ihm
an der hhl die leviten gelesen worden
vom zweiten bis zum dritten also kurz
vor den ferien war in einer negativen
phase
ich hatte eine diskussion mit dem
manager er sagte es sei nicht in ordnung
wie ich arbeite
das höre ich natürlich nicht gerne aber
es war die wahrheit ich merkte nicht wie
negativ geladen ich war
ich will kein schlechtes bild von mir
abgeben ich habe ein praktikum einige
sachen gelernt
in reifer geworden ich weiß jetzt wie
die ware arbeitswelt aussieht habe jetzt
großen respekt vor all den menschen die
diesen harten beruf ein leben lang
ausüben
für mich als vielleicht zukünftige hotel
war es richtig das zu verstehen wenn ich
diese leute für das war eine erleuchtung
für dich
[Musik]
heute schauen wir uns die berühmten
prioritäten an
wie läuft's beim praktikum es geht
es geht immer besser denn ich lerne das
metier immer besser kennen und ich habe
mehr freiheiten
da unten scharf rechts abbiegen
ja ja chef alex macht den führerschein
bei weitem nicht die einzige prüfung die
auf ihn wartet das problem ist dass sich
prüfungen nachholen muss 3 sogar
patisserie produktion und gourmetküche
kostet das war verdammt 300 franken pro
prüfung kannst du dir das vorstellen
dass es diebstahl eine prüfung 300 ja
unglaublich wie viele musst du machen
3 900 zum glück werde ich bezahlt und
lebe bei mama wohnen und essen gratis
denkmal an die das nicht alles haben
vielen dank nochmal
auch alexandra wird nach prüfungen
ablegen müssen einige die muss sich in
der august machen
ich werde ende monat beginnen mich
vorzubereiten
denn wenn ich eine prüfung versaue
könnte ich sechs monate lang nicht
weitermachen an der heil und müsste im
februar antreten
jetzt habe ich keine zeit für freunde
während seiner pause trifft alexandre
seinen vater der in einem benachbarten
luxushotel auf ihn wartet
ist die terrasse ausgebucht die ist voll
eine super erfahrung nicht eine gute
grundlage das geschäft zu lernen
es hat mir die augen für das mit je
geöffnet ich habe einiges verstanden und
das ist die grundlage
es ist eines der komplexesten
berufsfelder und eines der schwierigsten
zum organisieren
man muss viel wissen in der hotellerie
gibt es drei berufsbereichen die
beherbergung das restaurant und die
immobilie
das restaurant ist unser metier die
köche der service und alles was damit
zusammenhängt
auch das ist sehr komplex hinzu kommt
die immobilie in die wir investieren
ein hotel hat schöne räumlichkeiten um
zimmer
das ist eine große investition dieser
drei bereiche muss man kennen um ein
hotel zu führen
du bist auf dem weg das alles
kennenzulernen
ich bin zufrieden mit dir es ist hart
aber da musst du jetzt durch
wenn man mich fragt wer mein held ist
sage ich es ist mein vater er hat es
geschafft sich selbstständig zu machen
er ist mein vorbild
am seeufer von lausanne beginnt emma ihr
neues praktikum ein freundlicherer ort
als das grandhotel in genf wo sie ein
bisschen gelitten hat hier fühlte sich
viel besser eine restaurant war direkt
am see mit 360 grad aussicht auf den see
[Musik]
ich komme gleich wieder mit den karten
hier sind die speisen die pizzen sind
dort beim offen
der ist direkt hier in der küche ich
habe mühe damit nur drinnen zu arbeiten
ohne tageslicht im interkontinental
waren es acht bis zehn stunden hier bin
ich immer draußen ich kann während der
pausen baden gehen
es ist toll das team versteht sich super
wir haben zeit uns kennenzulernen
das intercontinental war eine ganz
andere welt
dort hatten wir sehr lange tage und
keine zeit um wirklich zusammen zu
arbeiten und uns kennenzulernen
[Musik]
annina und ihrer wg kochen eines der
letzten essen das sie gemeinsam
einnehmen als direktionsassistentin und
human resources stattfinden das bc 50
prozent direkte und 80 prozent im minus
auf es je nach damit beim berüchtigten
party leben der studenten hat annina
kaum mitgemacht nacht lang gehen wir
halt mit alter musik und megaphone
litern hochstellen irgendwie zieht
verbringen damit eigentlich kann
schlafen will er 11 so viel los und
urlaube aber nichts kommen richtig
beziehung zum menschen freunde treten
gerade am elite team ist aber angesichts
im unterricht und denn wenn ich liebe
was ich denn arbeit mit annelie zu
bringen
ende einer ära ende des wg lebens nach
drei jahren und witwe ist ziehe vor
allem wenn wir genau weiß was kommt noch
haar und der es ist doch so gut aber
wahrscheinlich es genau darum so gut
weil man weiß dass man es nicht für eben
irgendwie so hätte also ich glaube nicht
dass der verbrecher am besten ist es
glaube ich am besten wiederbewaldung
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
letzte stunden im luxushotel in dem
alexandra sein praktikum beendet heute
ist er gar nicht in form
ich war schon lange nicht mehr so müde
von der arbeit ich habe ein bisschen
abschied gefeiert und die letzten nächte
wenig geschlafen
wirst du die kollegen vermissen einige
jahr andere nicht mit der einigen gab es
schwierigkeiten
das hält sich die waage
wie verlief das praktikum mit alexandre
kompliziert hart
es ist immer schwierig mit den jungen es
ist unser job diese burschen erfolgreich
vorzubereiten auf die zukunft ich hoffe
wir haben ihm etwas positives
beigebracht
der letzte morgen des praktikums für
emma die den hochbetrieb fast vermisst
schlechtes wetter schade ich glaube die
leute bleiben in der stadt
wir haben keinen fünf sterne anspruch
weder vom niveau her noch von den
uniformen
wir versuchen jedoch wenigstens einen
fünf sterne service zu bieten auch wenn
das nicht offensichtlich ist immer hat
sie schnell angepasst in unseren
rhythmus das schätze ich
man muss hin und her rennen immer hat
sich toll entwickelt
ich habe sie bereits für nächste woche
eingeteilt sie wird weiter hier arbeiten
während des studiums natürlich je nach
verfügbarkeit
das vorbereitungsjahr war ja kein
studium deshalb freue ich mich jetzt
wirklich zu studieren
es werden regelmäßig ihre arbeitsstunden
seien
das wird mir gut tun
[Musik]
der letzte tag von alex sehnlichst
erwartet ich bin glücklich das praktikum
nun abzuschließen
es hat spaß gemacht aber ich bin froh
dass es fertig ist zwar lang und hart
und nach diesen sechs monaten werde ich
drei nach prüfungen schreiben müssen
nächsten mittwoch donnerstag und freitag
die praktikanten sind zu einem abschieds
aperitif eingeladen
ich muss nachschauen hin wenn ich mir
alles ist waren sie hat die sechs monate
ja anstrengend
sie sind ja hier um zu lernen nicht sie
waren hier noch sind wir da schreibt
einen hashtag ein schlüsselwort das eure
erfahrung beschreibt darf ich beginnen
weil ich stolz darauf bin was dieses
unternehmen für mich gemacht hat und das
sich in schwierigen situationen nicht
aufgegeben habe gut gemacht ist ihr klar
geworden wie wichtig das bild ist dass
du von dir vermittelt ja ich weiß dass
ich nicht immer so seriös
in der schule kann man faxen machen und
man kann sagen nicht schlimm da ist ja
noch ein kind aber in der arbeitswelt
musst du dich benehmen wie ein
erwachsener
jetzt lassen wir es knapp
fürbitten
[Musik]
es ist auch die stunde der bilanz für
alexandra mein charakter hat es mir
schwer gemacht
ich bin offen und ehrlich ich habe
einige verbesserungsvorschläge gemacht
aber es wurde immer als arrogant und
respektlos empfunden
ich bin in einem hotel aufgewachsen und
sehe was funktioniert und was nicht
war der einzige der mutig genug war die
dinge beim namen zu nennen
das hat viele probleme verursacht ein
langes und hartes jahr geht zu ende
das praktikum hat mir die augen geöffnet
mein vater ist hotelier deshalb wollte
ich in dieses metier einsteigen aber ich
habe gesehen dass es nicht meine domäne
vielleicht werde ich manager oder
besitzer eines hotels es wäre
interessant aber in der hotellerie
selbst arbeiten
[Musik]
hat annina die angestrebten zehn von
zehn exzellenz punkten erreicht
die diplomfeier für annina ist es die
kräne
abschluss mit heiko roß
[Applaus]
die großmutter link teil am triumph
ihrer brillanten enkelin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
draußen wird das ehrenspalier
schnurgerade ausgerichtet
[Applaus]
ja
ich habe viele reich bvh jonas becker
ich muss sagen ich bin sehr stolz dass
ich genauso viel geschafft und die
touristen serie und jetzt es doch
geschafft
ich bin viele unabhängige wurde und
selbständiger auf wo sie sagen am anfang
auch die unsere ist vollzählig auf die
cisco und ich habe mich mit weg und der
wahrscheinlichen ist in einem alter ein
boot durch immer mehr zahlen schlager am
besten kenne classics praktiker gruppe
projektteams
sobald man sich wieder bisschen wohl
fühlt wird mir witze pusht und
erreichten für ganze fast alle waren
entsetzt
[Musik]
monate sind vergangen seit dem abschluss
von afrim aber er bereitet seine zukunft
vor ohne überstürzung den shop hinten ja
aber nicht irgendein wenn ich in einem
jahr nicht das finde was ich will
breche ich ab es ist cool leute zu
treffen aber ich muss ja meine wohnung
etc bezahlen solange ich so weitermachen
kann werde ich es auch tun wenn ich die
hoffnung verlieren sehen wir weiter ich
bin sehr wagemutig aber zurzeit stehe
ich nicht unter druck
auf geht's
heute ist auch für afr ihm ein ganz
besonderer tag
er nimmt teil an einer einzigartigen
zeremonie jetzt kannst du dich noch über
diese ausländer beschweren aber in ein
paar minuten sind alle schweizer
das ist die letzte chance ich habe schon
ein paar fehler gesehen ein paar sind
mit dem taxi gekommen und stehen nicht
hinten an sondern drängen direkt rein
wird nicht sehr schweizerisch die haben
den pass noch nicht was wird sich
verändern
ganz konkret vieles vor allem für
jemanden der einen kosovarischen pass
hat er nicht in allen ländern akzeptiert
wird
es gibt länder in die ich gar nicht rein
komme ich wollte zum beispiel mal mit
der schule nach china aber es war für
mich nicht möglich
sobald ich alles kosovare europa
verlassen wollte brauchte ich ein visum
eine riesen prozedur
meine damen und herren guten tag und
herzlich willkommen
alle erforderlichen formalitäten des
waadtländer gesetzes sind erfüllt außer
der zeremonie zu der sie einberufen
worden sind wir beginnen diese zeremonie
mit der lektüre der gesetzlichen formel
nachdem ihr name aufgerufen worden ist
heben sie die rechte hand und sagen ich
gelobe es
noch ein abriss
[Musik]
ich gelobe
gratulation
wie viele jahre integration 28 jahre
ich weiß noch nicht ob ich es verdient
habe aber ich fühle mich gut wirst du
dieses diplom einrahmen
das wäre schon wird
[Musik]
dieses sommerende ist entscheidend für
alexandra ich bin heute hier um die
bäckerei prüfung zu wiederholen
ich habe mich gut vorbereitet ich weiß
nicht wieso ist nicht klappen sollte
ich bin zuversichtlich und hoffe zu
bestehen um ein jahr fortzusetzen
[Musik]
die letzte von drei prüfungen dass wir
klappen drei nachprüfungen ja drei in
der ersten 74 von 80 in der 2
76 von 80 punkten und nun schauen wir
mal
[Musik]
alle kommst du von der prüfung
ja es gab technische problem mit den
tablets deshalb sagt er ein wenig
verspätet
es war nicht alle fragen verfügbar das
wurde geklärt ich bin vor einigen
minuten fertig geworden
die ergebnisse spannung
alex muss noch die nachprüfungen
bezahlen das ist teil des spiels logisch
dass ich es bezahlen und nicht meine
mutter bitte hier unterschreiben
ich habe eine dummheit gemacht war zu
spät
ich nehme die konsequenzen in kauf auch
wenn es viel kostet
[Musik]
anhänger hat beschlossen so schnell wie
möglich in die arbeitswelt einzusteigen
sie hat ihren wunschjob gefunden beim
personal dienst eines grossen berner
hotels bucht nach abschluss vom studium
oder reiseerfahrung so gesetzt dass
sogar das ist davor stehen die offiziell
dem baby bekomme dass es vier jahre
stumme hat jetzt die erfahrungen sammle
und direkt ins wirtschaft erkannt und
reden aber wenn es so rasch nach dem
abschluss an
für unsere ehemaligen vorbereitungsjahr
studierenden heißt es zurück an die
schule
die ergebnisse der nach prüfungen sind
nun bekannt
ich habe eine prüfung von 12 versaut
weinkunde elf habe ich bestanden ich
falle durch wegen 0,15 punkten und kann
nicht weitermachen
ich bin sehr enttäuscht und wütend auf
mich selbst
ich muss die prüfungen erneut
wiederholen im februar verliere
viereinhalb monate zeit
trotzdem gebe ich nie auf bei
fehlschlägen ich denke positiv und ich
werde alles geben damit das nicht erneut
geschieht
alex hat bestanden und bestaunt die
baustelle des neuen campus
er wird erst fertig wenn wir weg sind
verdammt
wir haben es geschafft jungs auch emma
ist zurück froh aber auf ihre weise
ich habe ein bisschen angst aber ich
werde es schaffen
ich gebe mein bestes um keine nach
prüfung machen zu müssen das kostet viel
und ist mühsam aber du musst keine nach
prüfung machen nein ich habe
glücklicherweise alle prüfungen mit
guten durchschnitt bestanden
ich bin froh und hier ist miss europe
der botschafter der werte der immer
gerne witze macht willkommen zurück nur
kurz es gibt ganz viele veränderungen
und wenn sie mit veränderungen nicht
klarkommen kommen sie auch mit
herausforderungen nicht zu recht
vergessen sie das nicht aber ich habe
noch eine sehr gute nachricht bei der
kleiderordnung gibt es keine änderung
[Musik]
der dresscode ist unverrückbar
aber sonst hat sich alles verändert
alexandre bekam eine lektion wird er die
konsequenzen ziehen immer ist in
berührung gekommen mit der schwierigen
welt eines großen hotels wie wird sie
sich entscheiden
alex findet dass er nicht für die
hotelwelt gemacht ist welche richtung
wird er einschlagen afr ihm weckt pro
und contra wird er den shop seiner
träume finden kann annina den kurs der
exzellenz beibehalten
[Musik]
die hotelfachschule lausanne ist wie ein
bienenhaus in dem tausende menschen sich
begegnen zusammenleben und dann in allen
richtungen ihren honig suchen
[Musik]